actually danny can you kick into this
conversation shortly because next up was
far cry 4. perhaps like the most
exuberant just like
balls out wacky video game action
craziness
that elephants elephants like boring
cars you know sort of you know and you
know a yak is going to get it
because it has a far cry 3 the way that
creatures were but it seemed like at
every step they've sort of like
yes he's going to he's going to he's
going to push that barrel over and blow
it up you know like it just seemed like
new stuff yeah all right let's talk
about the grapple and the wingsuit this
was cool this was seriously sorry yeah
sorry no no it's all right man uh like
this just is kind giving you the kind of
environmental freedom uh that i think
you need when you take the level design
and put it up into mountains you get a
huge amount of verticality you need a
way to ascend as quickly as you can
descend and boom you get it right there
the grapple hook and the wing suit and
then sort of a this crossbow
infiltration and uh we're coming up on
this barrel stunt oh here we go i just
love this like the
like genuinely like far cry 4 was three
was great for loads of reasons the world
was fun like it was colorful it was all
that skinny nonsense but like genuinely
the the invading bases stuff was just
great it was like best in class that's
happened in years like reminded me of
like playing like really classic like
rainbow six games or project igi but
like you know and that and ground zero
saying i've done a really great job of
the whole base infiltration stuff so to
see like them concentrating on this in
the trailer is like delightful it means
like the freaking tuk-tuk
that's got like a weird radio and it's
playing like the local yeah crazy stuff
and then this nonsense happens well this
is awesome for two reasons one shooting
guns from vehicles uh you know that and
that's just
but this part this this sequence right
here the pull alongside the jump into
the truck and then what what happens to
the truck then it's just that kind of
open world mayhem we're gonna watch it
play out but uh one of the things that
you know wing suiting in the mountains
fantastic and this whole sequence just
makes me love the game instantly but
right after this a co-op partner joins
player two joins and they both cause the
mayhem together one dude is hovering in
this freaking gyrocopter thing
and then the other is on the ground and
they're like in it together for a little
while they got the you got the freaking
i don't know just everything about this
like
even seeing the elephants and then what
they end up doing but like so yeah
they've talked about the co-op stuff i'm
wondering is it just two-player they had
four player in the previous one but it
was instance based i wonder again as
like it was this guy in
his world before he arrived did he just
bump into him was like well so the one
thing they were saying was that you
don't need to own this game
yes oh yeah that was the thing how crazy
is that yeah so that makes yeah that
makes me think that you know you're
either playing campaign with like co-op
available like you're open to people
joining yeah or maybe you decide i just
want to join people as a co-op partner
because i mean these are it's clearly
two different characters right yeah but
yeah let's talk about that
on only on playstation 4 right i said
would you be able to play the game with
friends who don't own the game yeah i've
never heard of that with any i can't
think of any game that comes to mind
doesn't mario kart have some sort of
feature like that the ds does it the ds
does it a few times you can download a
small version of the game to another ds
and play it without having the car so
it's not like a totally foreign concept
but certainly on a home console like
that it is
and seemingly a powerful way to demo the
game you know because you're building
into that demo experience
the
joining you know and being with someone
who has the full capabilities perhaps i
presume
that they will be doing this to try and
get more people to buy far cry as well
you know i'm sure there's a there's a
it's an amazing thing to do you know
it's an amazing thing to do and i i
can't believe they've done it frankly
it's it's just it's just super cool it's
been pretty exciting to see that one
play out